(Transcribed by TurboScribe.ai. Go Unlimited to remove this message.) Чудово.
Тоді в нас ситуація в запис.
Можемо розпочати наш тижневий стендап.
Загалом я бачу, що в нас все ж
таки лише перша команда.
Є тому чудову можливість запитати, який прогрес загалом
по проекту, чи є якісь проблеми, незрозумілості, чи
потрібна в чомусь допомога.
Поки що проблема тільки в тому, що у
нас немає часу дороблювати проект.
Нас зараз трошки запрягли, нам треба до кінця
наступного тижня вже з дипломами закінчити.
Тому зараз у нас трошки проблема з часом.
Я зрозумію.
В основному, я думаю, я ще встигну до
п'ятниці ще одну-дві сторінки зробити, щоб
вже було…
А далі вже, думаю, Станіслав з базами даними
почне розбиратися.
Добре, ну загалом дивіться, в нас, якщо я
пам'ятаю правильно, останнє заняття – це буде
презентація проєктів.
Це буде десь в останню п'ятницю 23
-го.
Якщо не помиляюсь, то 23-го у вас
заняття мають бути.
Тому 23-го буде останній, ну загалом, презентація.
Тобто розраховуйте на те, що у вас ще
є фактично два тижні на завершення більш-менш
проєктів.
Тобто останні тиждень, ну фактично три тижні.
Тобто три з половиною тижні на те, щоб
закінчити тоді проєкти.
Дивіться, тоді на наступне заняття ми будемо, все
ж таки було б добре розглянути більш детально
базу даних, тому що минулого разу в нас
трошки не вистачило часу.
Я думаю, що будемо дивитись по ситуації, але
можна буде взяти когось, у кого буде можливість
працювати, створити аккаунт, і можна буде спробувати підключити
базу даних, ну і загалом оглянути, як і
що робити.
І, що також планувалось, ми тоді спробуємо завантажити
це все на сайт.
Ну хоча б, навіть якщо у вас не
буде серверної частини, то я поясню, як це
підключити, щоб можна було прямо з GitHub отримувати
HTML файл.
Тобто ви зможете вже навіть той сайт, який
у вас є, завантажити його, і він буде
чудово працювати на GitHub-і без будь-яких
додаткових налаштувань.
Тому що це буде також досить важливо.
Добре, тоді загалом, якщо питань немає, тому що
можемо і закінчити тоді.
Я думаю, що будете дивитись, щоб ви встигли
приблизно по розробці.
Ви казали, що до кінця цього тижня доробити
треба дипломні роботи.
Ну це зрозуміло.
Ну наступного тижня, не цього, а наступного.
Ага, наступного, добре.
Тобто у вас буде щонайменше навіть після того
два тижні на розробку.
Так, я думаю, що цілком встигнете, тому що
ми будемо розглядати більш детально це все.
І так як у вас вже є фактично
дизайн, основний та контент частина, тому я думаю,
що не мало б бути проблем.
Мало б все встигнути.
Ну або ж якщо будуть якісь проблеми, то
ви завжди можете поговорити з колегами.
Тобто якщо у вас є якісь теми, які
вам не зрозуміли, то ми можемо завжди це
розглянути на занятті лабораторному.
Проділити більш детально ті частини.
Добре.
Чудово, тоді призупиняю.